hello American people I would like to
talk about this relationship I'm in I'm
very happy in the relationship but I
regret not having more sexual adventure
in the past when there were
opportunities I was frigid and shy I
remember being at a party and I was in a
bedroom surrounded by like three young
attractive men one of them turns to me
and says we should have an orgy and I
said this is a nice room I can't go back
even if I could my personality is not
suited to an orgy why bring to a social
setting is humor that is not required at
all Jim nobody wants to be sarcastically
fellated how is the audio is such a
witty night so witty
but the relationship I'm in now is great
because there is authenticity there's
such honesty if we see somebody
attractive in the room we will talk
about that person being attractive this
is such a contrast to relationship I was
in years ago where there was such
insecurity I ended up having to say no I
don't think anyone is attractive and
it's weird because before I met you but
they must have what moved and he would
test me all the time say what about him
you think he's attractive well I mean I
think he's a model but no I mean I'm
sure he photographs well but I can't
bear to look at him whereas in this
relationship that I'm in we will go and
see a dance performance and we'll talk
about the magic of the movement and the
fluidity of the dancers and underneath
all of that were comfortable knowing
that what we're saying is be nice to
take one home and ruin his life
we should be able to do that because the
tickets are so expensive so I was in
France with him recently and it is the
most authentic beautiful relationship
I've ever been in and they were
croissants and and I think I think even
even though it's perfect even though I
love him still somehow I fall asleep
next to him and I have a dream that I'm
being seduced by this wet dungeon boy
and not wet from water covered in
lubricant and I should have known it was
a dream because it was too much
lubricant and I said I said to the boy
I'm in a relationship I can't really get
involved it's very nice of you to bring
me but then I couldn't stop him and I
think because he was so slippery and we
did all kinds of sordid wonderful things
together but I thought I portrayed the
best relationship I've ever been in what
am I going to do then I woke up I was in
France everything was fine but then for
the next three days all I could think
was I really love that a sex dungeon and
is that Who I am because you can't argue
with the unconscious and then all I'm
thinking is you know and I know that you
know I love the sex dungeon it's not
ideal long-term but all I can think then
is I really loved it and is not who I
really am because everything now in my
life just seems so polite to
conventional would you like this cross
all no I want to shove this pano
Chocolat up your bottom
your body's so dry any questions thank
you very much
[Applause]
you